tom we want to ask you about spider-man
3 of course you posted in january this
awesome picture i think it was your
little bro on your shoulders
talk to me a little bit about that why
was that so special uh it was very
special it actually that idea was
uh born because of jerry my brother
harry has a small little
cameo in this film where he plays a
character called the shaker kid
so we now have this ongoing joke that
the shaker kid is going to appear in
every movie that i'm in
um so the idea came from a barbecue john
watson director came over
and harry sort of said listen man i've
been here since the beginning when are
you going to put me in this film
and we found a little role for him just
as a joke really but it's really funny
and he does really well in it too
and i think fans will be very pleased to
see what we've gotten doing in this one
sometimes i feel like i've already seen
everything that's gonna happen
and it's a nightmare tom uh talk to me a
little bit about this role this is quite
the departure from what most fans are
familiar
with your work as as spider-man was
there any
uh apprehension in in taking the role
and
why did you take it what made you jump
into this amazing portrayal of this
character
yeah i mean naturally there was
apprehension just because
for a while i didn't think that i was
the guy for the job
just because i'd never done anything
like this before and i was just very
nervous that i wasn't going to be able
to
live up to what the russos wanted me to
try and achieve
once i'd had that conversation with them
and they sort of
explained to me how they believed that i
could do it and they trusted in me to do
a good job
i felt ready to kind of accept this
challenge and i think the reason i did
it is because
you know we're lucky as actors that we
work in a business where every job is
different you get to find things that
push you in ways you could never have
imagined
and i love a challenge i love doing
things i've not done before i love
traveling the world i love working in
places i haven't been i love meeting new
people
so it was an easy decision for me really
tell me a little bit about the
physicality of the character now
you've been in shape before this is not
new to you with spider-man did you
really lose 30 pounds for this thing and
compare kind of getting in shape for
spider-man versus getting in shape for
cherry what does that look like
i lost 27 pounds josephine russo really
likes to uh
round up paul which i lost oh three
pounds
i know but i know i just yeah it was
very different
and um it was running every day i wore a
bin bag and a hoodie and got sweaty and
i didn't eat it's very very different
type of training to what we do for
spider-man
the spider-man stuff is all about
strength training and fitness and
making sure i can maintain that athletic
ability throughout the course of the
film
cherry was the complete opposite and it
was brutal i hated it i absolutely hated
it i remember sort of six weeks into
shooting my team sort of saying to me
like
will you please eat something because
you are so insufferably miserable right
now
we just don't we need you to eat
something so
so yeah it was tough i mean it it paid
off
whatever you did you did it right now
sierra i'm not gonna let you off the
hook on this one
tell me about the seriousness of playing
a character like this
you're dealing with addiction you're
dealing with these different things how
dark do you have to get
into a place in your mindset to to kind
of be these characters and were you and
tom able to
kind of keep it light in between takes
yeah there's a lot of responsibility
approaching a part like this
you know this is a story that is so
personal to so many people across
not only the united states but the
entire world
and i just want to make sure that we
were doing
that journey justice um i was lucky that
we had such an incredible team of people
i mean tom was the best partner i could
have ever asked for and the brothers
were
incredible leaders and they made sure to
keep things
to create a safe environment that
allowed us to go to the places that we
really needed to go to which
could be very dark and really really
scary but i knew that
i'd have a partner next to me that
understood where i was going and
you know that he was going to be there
right by my side to catch me if i fell
and that the brothers were going to make
sure we were
staying safe and most importantly sane
during the shooting of this movie and
and were you able
to both stay well within these
characters
and sane or was it really affecting you
guys mentally
i mean listen like it's almost
impossible to go to the places that you
have to go to
in this movie and stay fully sane like
of course it's gonna happen
i don't speak for me personally of
course it's gonna have some effect on
you like i'd be lying if i said i didn't
cry in my trailer
at least once while shooting this movie
it was totally necessary and
and i was willing to go there and i
would do it again in a heartbeat
um what's important is i feel
healthy and happy now um so that's good
sometimes i feel like i've already seen
everything that's gonna happen
and it's a nightmare
you